Voix off:
Vortex, portails, voyages temporels.
De tous temps les hommes ont été fascinés
par ce saut vers l'inconnu et ont tenté,
à travers de nombreuses œuvres de fiction,
de reproduire ce qui leur semblait impossible.
Mais voyager dans le temps est-il réellement
impossible? Les propos de cette jeune femme,
filmée par nos caméras, pourraient
nous ouvrir une voie où tout serait possible.
La Prof:
Ça a commencé dans mon précédent logement.
J'étais dans ma chambre, et tout à coup
j'ai senti une présence.
Voix off:
Vous voulez dire, fantomatique?
La Prof:
Ah non bien réelle et bien vivante.
Elle portait une robe ancienne et disait s'appeler
Aliénor et venir du XVe siècle.
Voix off:
Et qu'est devenue cette présence, par la suite ?
La Prof:
J'ai du l'héberger chez moi, je ne pouvais
pas la laisser sortir comme ça.
Mais il y en a eu d'autres...
Une viking, un révolutionnaire, une pirate...
Ça fait des mois que je vois défiler des
personnes d'autres époques défiler chez moi,
sans aucune explication!
Voix of:
Vikings, pirates, pictes, cette jeune historienne
a vu défiler dans son salon des dizaines
de preuves de l'existence de phénomènes
surnaturels, elle qui se contentait de les
étudier dans des livres d'histoire jusque là.
Et vous pensez que votre appartement pourrait
se situer sur un portail
ou un ancien cimetière indien?
La Prof:
Un cimetière indien... En France ?
Non, d'autant que le phénomène
a continué quand j'ai déménagé.
Dans mon logement suivant une romaine,
Lucretia, a débarqué
et ne décolle plus de mon canapé.
Les autres sont partis vivre leur vie au XXIe
siècle, mais Aliénor et Lucretia squattent
toujours chez moi...
Et je ne sais plus quoi faire.
Voix off:
Sommes-nous vraiment entourés de voyageurs
venus d'époques reculées? Comment sont-ils
arrivés parmi nous, et quelles sont leurs
intentions à notre égard?
Un dossier qui renferme encore bien des mystères,
et que nous ne sommes probablement pas près
de refermer.
Et vous? Croyez-vous aux voyages temporels?
Avez-vous déjà croisé un voyageur venu
des temps reculés? Venez témoigner en
commentaire et sur Twitter grâce au hashtag
#TimeWarp.